according to the Neilson total audience
report in quarter one of 2017 the
average American adults spent about
eleven hours and 18 minutes a day
consuming media content this got me
thinking if we didn't have such easy
access to unlimited entertainment what
would we spend our time Oh Burt what
would we spend our time on hobbies
laundry building an indestructible
empire to answer this question I
persuaded three of my all too trusting
co-workers to take the plunge and stop
streaming for a week there's not a day
go without watching Netflix I watch it
when I get ready immediately when I come
home or when I'm cooking like in the
background for like white noise now that
I'm talking about it I realized I may
have a problem
I literally stream things every second
I'm on my bed or on my couch I'll drop
by my house and watch I'll stream
something for lunch you go home and
string things yeah I definitely watch
once a day if not twice sometimes I let
myself watch it why put my makeup on in
the mornings but that's a treat murder
documentaries the Oh a love Game of
Thrones love broad city specs in the
city of this is awesome girls on HBO
insecure right now I'm addicted to
Vampire Diaries again why I don't know
so I really want to deep clean my
apartment but I keep getting distracted
reading is the biggest thing for me
because I have like a bookshelf of books
that I have read like five pages of each
all right so you said you really liked
The Handmaid's Tale yes oh my god I got
you some other books by my girl
oh and then you also said you wanted to
organize I do so I got you a drawer
organizer I've always wanted to learn
how to cook everyone around me knows
that I can't cook also my boyfriend
loves board games if I had a choice
between board games are streaming I'd
rather watch something this might
encourage us to play more board games so
I got you a game of Thrones cookbook oh
and then I also got you a board game
this feels nicer than screaming I'm
getting presents I think one of the
things I would do is definitely work out
more because I have a gym in my
apartment and I like haven't even been
in it just
yep okay so first I have a book cuz you
said you loved the ocean and this seemed
like a really good book you did say you
wanted to exercise more so I got you a
kit to exercise at home although I do
have a gym at my apartment
I am shy to go workout in front of
people so cool no that's a great idea
I'm excited now just informed my sister
I'm doing this new streaming thing and
she wanted to watch English TV while we
eat and she's not too pleased life
outside of Netflix real life is hard
okay not only do I have to fill this up
halfway today with the foot pump I have
to wait 24 hours to continue to fill it
up I'm standing in front of my TV I just
got home and I'm gonna unplug my
chromecast which helps me stream things
from my computer and phone unplugging
the ground and my boyfriend really
wanted to watch TV so he is while I'm
not facing it and facing the window
literally just sitting here so Maya told
me that she streamed an episode of the
our Diaries last night that's against
the rules I'm afraid but before I
started this it was I was watching like
the last episode before the end of the
entire series I couldn't stop you
couldn't wait okay so I do have to tell
you a spoiler for being the one who are
you in season 3 episode 10 Jane the
virgin what wait I'm gonna cry but I'm
done with Netflix or not I learned your
lesson that was the most like oh and I
also found out that Kane watch Game of
Thrones to be fair it was the Game of
Thrones season premiere so maybe I was a
little harsh and expecting him to not
watch that well look what we have here I
did so well I experienced life on a new
level and then Game of Thrones came out
and I was just having so much Momo we're
gonna give you a spoiler from how to get
away with murder I have not seen this
show so this police means nothing to me
there's a character named Wes
apparently no that's your life that's
very sad
[Music]
so just what a crazy person at this
insane boot camp thing
and usually I come home just be like
chill and watch TV and I can't
so I'm doing a puzzle like an
eight-year-old looks at first cup filled
it up and it came with um this little
thing but uh I think we're gonna use
this in the pool all right we're about
to work out with this thing
it's a weekday and instead of streaming
something we're gonna play Game of
Thrones monopoly got this the TV is no
song and I I'm gonna read this book like
a grown-up who doesn't need TV to
entertain them last night was the first
time I actually decided to read but like
the last 20 minutes been being awake and
I had forgotten how calming reading
actually is it was like a really nice
time juice all I want to do is lay in
bed and watch Netflix hello darkness my
old friend
so I've had a super long day and I'm so
exhausted and I just want to lie down
and watch TV and I'm wondering if DVDs
count we actually went and got pillows
for the apartment we went to a live
comedy show at UCB it was nice to
explore the city and not stay in our
environment today's the last day of not
being able to stream and I'm so excited
and I'm excited to watch Netflix
whenever I want nice room for a week was
really great I'm pretty happy to be done
with not dreaming honestly I hate when I
get told I can't do something cuz then I
want to do it even more
it definitely felt like a better person
for not streaming all the time because
do you feel like a lazy [ __ ] I do
that I played a lot of board games I
cooked a lot we finally finished our
apartment I was a lot more productive
during the week I tried to set up that
exercise ball but it was so difficult
and I tried to read but it was so
difficult to focus I did read one of my
short stories and I thought I threes the
second one but I haven't got any further
so instead I ended up singing with my
ukulele like every single night and
ended up like posting stuff on Instagram
like I used to and it was like great it
was great to do that again it felt so
good I definitely would want to continue
this maybe like half of the week no
streaming you know I definitely want to
try and stream less now I definitely
feel like I can get more done and I
don't need it as much but it would be I
think it's just being allowed to have it
is what I mean I would definitely do a
streaming purge again just because I did
so much creatively that I haven't done
within this past year and I think it's
good to do everything on moderation and
to take breaks I cannot wait to get back
so this is us because I was so in the
middle of getting excited about that
show and then I has just cut it off so
can i watch netflix now
I guess it's safe to sure cool I was
about to watch it on my phone
what
[Music]